[موسيقى]
الفكر الحركي
قدم المملكه العربيه السعوديه في وقت مبكر
جدا يعني حتى يمكننا ان نقول ان اول تنظيم
للاخوان المسلمين في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه كان عام
1937 للميلاد يعني بعد انشاء جماعه
الاخوان في مصر ب 9 سنوات تقريبا
طبعا حسن البنا عندما كان ياتي الى موسم
الحج همم يعني عامل على انشاء هذا التنظيم
طبعا بشكل غير معلن همم حاول جست نبض همم
المملكه العربيه السعوديه من خلال طرحها
على الملك عبد العزيز رحمه الله همم فكره
انشاء فرع الاخوان ورد عليه الملك عبد
العزيز غفر الله له برد حاسم في هذا
الموضوع
ثم يعني توال النشاط هذه
الجماعات لكن لم يكن لها بريق لدى
المثقفين ولد النخب اييه وذلك
لان الوهج في ذلك الوقت كان ل- اا
التيارات القوميه واليساريه
شيوعي والبعث والناصر والقومي وما الى ذلك
فهذا الوجه كان مستمر في الخمسينات
الاربعينات الخمسينات الستينات حتى عام
1967 وهو مرحله انكسار هذا المد فاستغل
الحركيون الاسلام الامويون همم في طبعا في
العالم كله ومن بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هذا الامر وبداوا بناء القواعد
الشعبيه لهم ابتداء من عام تقريبا همم 67
بدا النشاط الفع الحركي في قطاعات التعليم
في المدارس
[موسيقى]